un scrutin qui n'a visiblement pas
intéressé les électeurs de la deuxième
circonscription l'abstention s'élève à
73,33% pour ce premier tour de la
législative partielle plus de 30 points
supplémentaires par rapport à l'élection
de juin dernier ce sera d'ailleurs le
même duel que lors de la dernière
législative Jean-Noël Barrault et Maïté
qui arrive bedouani se qualifie pour le
second tour le ministre de la transition
numérique et des télécommunications est
largement en tête il est en ballotage
favorable avec 42,29% des suffrages
obtenus je me félicite que les électeurs
aient confirmé leur choix en me
permettant de me qualifier pour le
second tour avec un score qui progresse
de 8 points au second tour le choix est
clair il y a d'un côté le camp des
réformes de la responsabilité de l'ordre
républicain et de l'autre celui de la
nups de Mélenchon du désordre et du
chaos
en deuxième position la candidate de la
nupes m'a été qui arrive bedouani qui
récolte 18,6% des voix moins quatre
points par rapport à la législative de
juin un recul qui peut s'expliquer selon
elle par la forte démobilisation des
électeurs une abstention qui touche les
jeunes générations
une génération qui ne croit plus en nos
politiciens de quoi est-ce qu'on a
besoin en fait est-ce qu'on a est-ce
qu'on a besoin de
constamment avec Jean-Noël barreau de
constamment reculer sur
les questions de climat reculer sur les
questions de droit social de service
public et du coup
s'engouffrer dans une instabilité une
insécurité
moi je continue mon combat en revanche
il n'a manqué que 182 voix Pascal
Thevenot 3e avec un score de 17,8% pour
se qualifier au second tour deuxième
dans sa commune le maire de
Vélizy-Villacoublay arrive même premier
au loge en Josas il n'a manqué que 180
voix pour être au second tour et
permettre de battre Jean-Noël Barrault
qui aurait été sans réserve de voir
malheureusement la candidature de
Laurence Trochu tantôt candidate de la
droite à Versailles tantôt candidate
d'extrême droite dans la circonscription
a été l'assurance vie de Jean-Noël
Barrault Laurence Trochu justement
termine en quatrième position avec 11%
devant Anne Jack main du rassemblement
national après la première
circonscription en juin dernier la
candidate de reconquête était cette
fois-ci en lice dans la deuxième
circonscription avec un peu plus de 20%
des suffrages le mouvement d'Eric
Zemmour se classe même deuxième à
Versailles preuve que les idées
conservatrices trouvent un certain écho
dans la cité royale second tour au
programme dimanche 9 octobre lors de
l'élection législative de gens 64% des
votants s'étaient exprimés la faveur de
Jean-Noël Barraud face déjà à Maïté qui
arrive bedoni